[Musique]
un récipiendaire du prix nobel japonais
qui affirme que le nouveau coronavirus a
été inventé en laboratoire ça fait une
excellente manche est et ça génère
déclic
mais c'est surtout faux selon cette
publication virale le prix nobel de
médecine de 2018 tasucu en joe aurait
soutenu que le corps à navires us ne
serait pas naturel et qu'il aurait été
en fait fabriqué par la chine le
principal intéressé qui enseigne à
l'université de kyoto au japon a été
parmi les premiers à démentir ces
affirmations par voie de communiqué et
je le cite je suis très attristé
d'apprendre que mon nom et celui de
l'université de kyoto ont été utilisées
pour répandre de fausses accusations et
de la désinformation
fin de citation selon l'université de
kyoto
infos au compte twitter en même usurpé
l'identité du chercheur pour propager
une kyrielle de fausses informations
parmi les faussetés associés aux
chercheurs nippons il ya le fait qu'il
aurait travaillé depuis quatre ans dans
le fameux laboratoire de virologie de
wuhan en chine
en réalité comme l'attestent ses deux
versions de son cv tasucu en jour n'a
jamais travaillé en chine et travaille
plutôt à l'université de kyoto depuis
1984 autre affirmation trompeuse
la publication virale affirme que le
corona virus ne peut pas être naturel
car il se serait propagée dans toutes
les régions dans tous les pays de la
même façon selon cette logique boiteuse
si le virus était d'origine naturelle il
n'aurait touché que les pays qui ont le
même climat que la chine une prémisse
sans fondement scientifique selon
l'immunologue tatiana scordia professeur
au département de sciences biologiques
de l'uqam dire que le comportement du
virus est égale partout est tout
simplement faux selon elle
madame scorza souligne que pour un virus
comme le strass cov 2 l'impact de la
température est minime
ce sont surtout les virus se transmet
par des vecteurs par des moustiques par
des insectes qui sont davantage modulée
par la température
quant à l'affirmation selon laquelle le
virus n'aurait pas d'origine naturelle
c'est totalement contraire à ce qu'ont
démontré l'ensemble des recherches
jusqu'à présent la revue nature a
d'ailleurs clairement démontré l'absence
de manipulation humaine
pour en savoir plus sur les fausses
affirmations associés à ce prix nobel
japonais je vous invite à lire l'article
de ma collègue bouchra wathiq sur notre
site web
et n'oubliez pas de regarder notre
émission diffusée les samedis et
dimanches sur les zones de ici rdi salut
[Musique]